All right, you're done.
There were a lot of new things
that time.
But, after all,
you're becoming a seasoned
Android programmer by now.
As I mentioned before,
we're going to use
NotificationCompat.Builder
to build our notification.
It's easy to build a nice looking
notification that has our icon
representing the weather forecast,
the title for our app.
And our content text, the forecast
with highs and lows.
We're going to use another class
from the support library,
to create a task stack builder
for our pending intent.
This is a simple case
of task stack builder,
because all we have
is a single item on our stack.
We just add the next intent
and use it to build out pending intent
that we pass
into the notification manager.
Finally we call the notification manager
with the built intent from our builder,
with a notify function.
One of the great things
about notification manager
is it can be used from any thread
even though it is displaying UI.